I mean coming from Europe as an Irishman
living in London many years Eurovision
Song Contest was a big event on TV and
remain so so it's all it's all the
European countries and they show their
greatest and finest singing acts and
they're quite outrageous some of them
they really go for it and it's very
humorous but it's very sincere and it's
very real and it's very important to all
the countries and it's taken to heart
and practically you know all the
countries of Europe they all close down
when the show comes on TV and of course
you know Abba is one of their finest
finest acts that you know lit out the
world and I remember when they won and
so Abbott seems to have played a part in
my life having done two movies I saw
mama me I loved it I loved every actor
and it's literally like they were like
so what actors do you want to see in a
film together that you love and then
Mamma Mia enters literally all all you
guys I love Mara I love the whole cast a
really cool thing like did you only
thing was that like have you sing in
front of audiences before no I mean I
sang when I was at drama school you had
to sing you had to do everything when
you're a student but no I I made a film
one of my little films with my company
Irish dream time I did sing and that was
a movie called Evelyn which is a
beautiful film yeah but I signed Irish
pub songs it's a lot different than
singing in Abba and singing you know a
warhorse song like SOS so it was mildly
terrifying and didn't employ me for my
for my singing talents it was you know
it was rough and ready but I think it
was played with such heart and such
sincerity the whole film I loved it
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going